بتوازي مشاهدينا مع المهمه الجديده
للمدمره ميليس بدات واحده من غواصات
البحريه الامريكيه المزوده بصواريخها
موجهه مهمه جديده في الشرق الاوسط الحديث
هنا عن الغواصه فلوريدات التي اكد المتحدث
باسم البحريه الامريكيه
انها دخلت منطقه الشرق الاوسط وعبرت قناه
السويس البحريه الامريكيه قالت ان الغواصه
تعمل بالطاقه النوويه ومزوده بصواريخ
موجهه وتعمل في الشرق الاوسط طبعا دعما
للاسطول الخامس الذي يتخذ من البحرين مقرا
له غواصه الصواريخ الموجهه فلوريدا تندرج
تحت فئه اوهايو وظلت لسنوات طويله من اكثر
المنصات تنوعا وسريه في اسطول البحريه
الامريكيه هي تحمل على متنها سته 66 عنصرا
من قوات العمليات الخاصه وتحمل اسم
الولايه 27 في الولايات المتحده منذ عام
تصنف كواحده من اربع غواصات مزوده بصواريخ
موجهه في اسطول البحريه الامريكيه وقد
اكملت اكثر من 50 دوريه قبل تحويلها الى
غواصه صاروخيه موجهه لدى غواصه فلوريدا
طاقمان الازرق والذهبي وتشمل حوالي 160
بحارا يتناوبون على تشغيلها وينتشرون عاده
مع السفينه لمده ثلاثه اشهر قبل التبديل
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات